dude the knife is way better than the
spear i'm not using this anymore dude
knife is way better in the spirit yeah
especially in combat that doesn't really
happen
[Music]
we're so weak in front of the knife
god watch one day wait i want to be a
cool spirit guy he's doing great you
know what to say nice guys finish last
is this the sucky sucky boy room yeah oh
yeah look it is that's a five five no
shootie remember shootie they all do
that's what kill us this is spear moment
two shining uh okay
get up
come on the door come on the door oh we
are so [ __ ] oh no oh god oh god the
bigs behind us are about to be such a
problem
[Music]
no
well actually these sentries are set up
in a pretty good position we should have
been out here because they're gonna
well this is oh it's a big end
hey sean is the floor coming i'm down in
front of him oh and i'm not down i'm
down now i don't know what's happening
here
hang on
that's a lot of big guys oh my god
yeah it's like all of them all of them
and we'll be fine ow
use the knife okay okay those tentacles
reach pretty far
yeah yeah i think we just skipped that
room what if we just leave uh uh that's
our objective
well maybe we maybe
i don't want to go in there anymore
that's what i've decided listen i need
to pee so bad i'm gonna pee i'm gonna be
like five seconds
we'd never do anything crazy without you
bob
quick act crazy
maybe what we should do is go to this
other area try to get some health packs
before we go there
yeah yeah yeah we could probably take
out well not all the big guys maybe but
we could take out some of them
uh if we had like a better setup for it
wait wait i got ammo for you oh thank
you what's over here
nothing as far as this goes well maybe
one
nothing
nothing
nothing
nothing
nothing
and a health pack
one use one use but that's health
it's better than oh
god there's some here
uh
you're right but yeah it's just a few
it's just a few items
all right so how's it going everybody we
good we're gonna go try to get more
health before we go to that place one
here
sleepers oh i'm hearing them from your
area okay yeah you go you get that one
on the ground i'll get this one over
here
coming for you [ __ ]
i saw at least one up top hey i found a
health pack literally right here yeah i
called it out no one picked it up i
don't know why okay well i got it i know
where i'm picking it up
when you called it out oh that was for
you guys it was for me he called out for
me it's fine he's like bob didn't kill
anything in this room he needs a win oh
god there's one more
oh
i got it taken out like a true knife
champion thank you thank you thank you
got a mine here that's going to be
helpful oh there's some more hold on to
that yeah there's still more in here
guys careful oh you're right
one more down there and that should be
okay there's a locked box right there
you know they say it would be if it
never boils
hey
that was better than the joke sean was
gonna say definitely
come help me with this i need yours yeah
i came flying up with my light out and
uh did not know you weren't a predictee
yeah a little bit of a predict if you
can get that that was such a classic
great joke good for you
[Laughter]
any of them it would be helpful
perfectly out of sync so no they're here
it's fine
it's fine it's fine they're fine are you
gonna screw me you guys should just
screw me right now what do i just turn
my light on oh hey there's a fourth one
he just lifted
up there's four yeah
oh they're all perfectly synced now all
right
from the left
perfectly synced all right cool as all
things should be all right all right you
guys ready i'll get this one down to the
left okay cool
all right three
two
one
one
oh we both went for the same one when
you said down to the left i think about
the one on the [ __ ]
slant it's all good man it's all good
there was one down here on the left i
thought this is the one you made yeah i
said i also have the one down to the
left i have the one directly in front of
me primarily oh well you spear boys
they're all the same
things you haven't even seen yet
see what i see plenty i see a tree
you're playing three card hold them and
i'm playing 5d chess that's the
difference between spears and knives it
hurts more i was smart
once
once upon a time i was smart i had used
to have been smart back in the days when
i was
smart i possessed intellect
it weren't only you it were also me
sometimes
oop oh uh there's one right around the
corner there yeah yeah yeah
i think it's pretty just the one so i
think yeah
you got it we're over here
got it
sometimes you gotta you gotta flash them
before you bash them i love when they
die like that some of them you get them
and they're like
and some of you get them and they're
just like
[Laughter]
that's the sound of
whatever these things are dying
sometimes i don't know you should
totally make a tick tock of you doing
that sound that would go viral
so it would go v rile that'd be so
fertile man dude
i don't make viral videos i make virile
videos
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
you got it you got it oh god it's not
fine no
i got him
why didn't you hit it why are you going
behind hit it
because there's more coming out hey oh
how did i just kill both of those
i don't know i'm getting like decent
because of ping issues i think oh
what an excuse
well my shots were didn't land last time
and the sun was in my eyes because i
picked
what we need
two sets of them
yeah we're not going to get any health
is this very clear i'm still hearing
like like quickly oh i'm sprinting
everywhere so i hope so uh i don't know
it's probably fine maybe
this with less health and less ammo than
we really are we really are how are
there so few goodies i want goodies no i
mean glow sticks
oh you're right you're right
i underestimated the glow sticks
door in emergency lockdown unable to
upgrade this door doesn't look like a
door i don't want to [ __ ] with at all
yeah we go through there it looks like
you really want to [ __ ] with it as well
we go through there next
that's the next day really none maybe
there's something over here it's like a
shiny door like a big red button door
there's technically another door right
here
what is a what is a solid red dot on my
radar means why is there a solid red dot
that's not really good not
oh i hear that wait this room is full of
people yes there's an open door leading
to a room
i'm here
my friend where are you you are not here
i'm right here oh hey there you are
you're here
the [ __ ] beans it's all good man
it's all good there was just another
door over here potential items so i was
like oh this room
i remember now
we've been here before have we yeah
oh yeah that one
we asked donuts before
no shot that i just make that mistake oh
i'm fixing my mistake i'm fixing my
mistake i'm fixing my mistake oh there's
a lot of mistake i'm also fixing your
mistake i fixed my mistake i mean i
killed like six of those deal with that
mistake
i feel like a thousand of them we're
fine
i didn't do that one that was mark i
didn't do that
they were coming from your previous
mistake no no that was all you i had
already fixed my mistake
no wait we killed all the ones in my
room there weren't any from my room
there's rooms beyond the one i'm in
you're saying that from like a thousand
meters away i alerted three rooms away
things with a tiny little mistake that i
fixed immediately yeah yeah i don't
think so sniper rifle
did you shoot it with us i didn't i know
i knifed them who was someone shooting a
knife
i had my shotgun out that was not a
shooting situation that was annoying
we're clear guys you can oh it's not my
fault so i fall i told you to bring a
spear and you brought a spear all right
guys let's take it down a notch let's
take it down does that sound like my
fault i don't think that's my fault i
think you're just making excuses now um
god get your [ __ ] hand in the way
[Laughter]
why
are you what are you doing man what you
doing i'm trying to are you using this
oh my god
what are you doing over there
does this help
there's a ping on a box we have an oh
[Laughter]
the box you pinged is a box that's
already open oh okay all right then then
it might wait it should uh whatever i'm
not i'm not the terminals don't know if
they're open uh you just know that they
exist you're right you're right you're
right how we looking on our scavenging
good health good oh oh so good before
less ammo but more experience
that's right and experience really is
the greatest gift a man can receive it
doesn't pay the bills all right same
stride as before
well they didn't come through that door
at all so i'm gonna put a turret outside
this thing i think well like we said
they just come through whatever they can
well right but you goofy both doors if
we do that again they still only came
through the top door all right we double
turned that door so if they come through
this one this time you can actually
throw a hissy fit yeah no i if they come
this down here i might reposition my
turret because
angrily though right yeah i know a real
real angle oh hey i wasn't over there
sorry i wasn't ready wasn't paying
attention
i don't think we ever are that's why i
do it okay it's gonna curve it's gonna
curve i knew it i knew the curve no
leans to the left hey look at this door
i swear to god i just know where your
turrets are
repositioning
wait wait wait oh everyone step back
step back step back place it
step away from it i forgot i had that
that was the one thing i got on the
scavenge
what did you get a mine stay away from
that door
nice nice nice
knife knife
okay they went through the uh
whoa that's quite a few
okay we're done on the scan
another wave another way of doing it
up top
why am i not it's like that door's still
there i can't shoot i i thought i was
wow
i just wasted a lot of ammo hitting
apparently an open door yeah for some
reason it's bugged
it's a little glitchy this round
it's all right okay i think we're good
why can't we ever do it like that all
the time i don't know man i don't know
all right
what if what if we uh
kill these guys
sure sure sure if i stand up on that
platform and snipe down as they come
through the door i can maybe just hit a
bunch of nasty shots well i'm thinking
that okay so from what i know about
hitting him in the back does double
damage hitting him in the back of the
head does triple damage one person hits
him in the back of the head the rest hit
him in the back
that should like a spear in the back of
the head and then everyone else in the
back it should kill it i want to test
its theory i've it should kill it oh god
what if we tried this guy in the right
first because he's on his own yeah
that's probably good shot good call good
call could call good call
if he feels confident about this oh stop
stop stop if he aggro is then word
it's fine okay
so
all in the back that's what we were
doing wrong last time some people were
hitting him in the front i think that's
why he was inconsistent yeah we were
like all around okay i'm ready ready all
right charging charging three three two
one
it's not that oh it's dead it's dead
it's it it's it
oh my god
we are fear
should we do this next one over here to
the right as well oh i have a high i
want to chase that dragon oh there's two
there let's go left because i think
there's boxes probably down were there
boxes down there whoever went down i
think there was one step
in position i have back of head again
[Music]
okay so if that other one aggros we back
up to the
other place yeah
yes let's do this i'll get the if he
agrees it'll be the whole room right
not necessarily we wait and see let's
just not hit it when it's pulsing okay
everyone ready to charge yeah let's wait
for the other one to finish its thing oh
i'm charged uh
right click
oh my god what you didn't say a word
back up back up back up
oh it's not dead
i'm down now no
there goes our sniping strat just back
up back away back all the way away like
into the following room
okay the other guy didn't aggro that's
good uh shot we're falling even further
back
yeah oh
there i go they're coming now
okay the two big guys
just run run
well i'm just gonna i'll just be here
when you guys get back
yep why is this not loaded
no not that not that
pull out a gun
oh
no oh my god
what how
how did it get me from around the corner
how much [ __ ] health do these things
have a lot a lot they're pretty big
okay all right all right i think that
would have worked if we were just a
little bit more
i as soon as you guys said right click
my charge ran out i'm sorry
all right so we know not to explore the
rest of the area because it's pointless
why
why
why
okay it's fine it's fine hey
we've been trying to read you about your
car's extended warranty ah it's so nice
to have a car
do you guys want to take out some of
these guys
bob miss nevermind i didn't miss i
didn't miss my guy died who missed what
happened well you messed up around the
moment no not right away i didn't miss
[ __ ]
he just died really awkwardly on my
screen it looked like he missed he was
still he like he like took a step and
then was like wait i'm dead and it fell
down yeah he said i had him ice cream
why he's so laggy this time i'm ready i
don't know man i don't know i don't know
oh you didn't kill him well i was
charging you already went ready to
charge why wouldn't you just hit him
he's go why didn't you
you should know the cadence by now have
a spear
but then you can hit him from farther
away look guys i know he's giving up
get a bad rap we're not homework that is
on point
okay
that seemed to work wait you could put
it on the other side here pointing like
down the stairs maybe well the one up
there was useful last time okay that's
fine too
i'm gonna save mine for kind of what we
did last time i think okay is it down
there putting up the stairs the first
place i went to put it you're all like
you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
no down the stairs
you're pointing down the stairs
[Laughter]
oh god i'm having childhood flashbacks
it's gonna be curvy right here
oh wait yeah these are the same uh
they're going at the down yeah they're
at the no they're at the yeah they're at
the down door i'm gonna uh i'm gonna do
it
i'm gonna do it who's here
oh hey we don't have the mine this time
that was useful yeah that was pretty
cool
that was good that killed a lot of them
all at once okay they're about to break
through the top
where i thought i was in it oops okay
here they come
that's a lot of them that's more than
i'd like i
can't run i'm retreating ow turret don't
you daddy [ __ ] you can we get some pinks
mark i can't see anything right you got
it well that's my shotgun
did you just pull it out just wham sure
did
well they were dead by the time we did
that but oh good you can ping through
the door you're right i can i will take
that
oh ah you're going upstairs i'm gonna
knife come on wade's turret watch this
watch this guys i'm brave i missed i
missed again i missed again he's so hard
on him
look how brave he is
i can't believe the bravery on display
my apm
damn he's going supernova
i couldn't even see him he was moving so
fast i didn't even know apm was a
permanent stat in this game but i feel
outmatched now yeah you've seen it
firsthand though yeah mark's got a knife
and 486 ppm what am i supposed to do
ah let's just sit back and watch man
just pick a spear like the rest of us
and obviously my keyboard doesn't even
have n key rollover
probably has an infinite scroll wheel
too oh hey i hate this you're here
already i forgot okay well we know the
strat now we just need to
do it carefully
mark i think everyone else chose
differently you're right i'll be i'll
meet i'll meet you there guys
and this guy has no spatial awareness
whatsoever we just snuck right hoop
somebody else called the chairs this
time all right uh everybody ready yep
huh charge them up charging
three two one got them
okay
us knives have to hit it again
to finish it that's enough
that seems to be this knife knife
there's one closer than that guy i can
see right oh there he is yep he's right
there
they're here you're stuck close all
right are we in position
closer
don't get in position okay i'm here
everyone in position yep yeah yeah
charge them up
three two one kill him
he dead oh this is beautiful this is
good this is good guys this is good
oh we're so sexy
we're stupid
yes
you have a spear charge them up charge
it
three two one get them
i got it we're good we're good i got it
kill shot in the anus wade have you been
aiming for the head the whole time
yeah
oh my god
i want it don't snap me back
i love how casual you are about
everything have you been in for the
heads all the time yeah
yeah
that's awesome
wrong so wait you've been missing is
what you're saying no no i'm actually
hit first i made sean miss
i hit the first two
oh well then we hit the same time
so knife guys don't have to hit twice
everyone clear yeah
no one close enough yeah yeah charge
them up charging
three two one got him
right in the head there he goes
all right there are two down there in
the darkness just fyi all right everyone
here no
not even close okay
i'm gonna have to send you a postcard
charge them up
no no no no no no no no no
i'm in position all right everyone's in
position i'm here
charge them up charging
three two one
someone stepped inside wow look at that
we didn't have to hit a second time
straight away yeah headshot
okay be very careful he's here somewhere
there he is
in the darkness
to charge him up
three two one get him
headshot oh god he's not gonna be the
only one he's alive he's live he's alive
no he's dead he's dead
god what did you do wade what did you do
i went right for the spinal cord baby i
got it are there more in here or what
more there are more up top but not
straight above us so we're pretty good
right here
um
i could use a tool uh wade could
probably use a tool yeah we could use
tool yeah i can pick up the seafoam
there no health but whatever
it's ah we're fine
stop saying hedgehog
i think you're actually triggering mark
right now
i think it was just i think there were
just like uh some artifacts here i'm
gonna pick up real quick i don't think
anyway didn't we kill
hey guys i just want you to know let's
go
we should be quiet oh we should be quiet
cool we should go quiet uh there's a c
phone here if anyone has space i can't
stack them apparently i no they don't
stop no what we should probably do is
we'll we'll just assume we're gonna trip
the tentacles what we should do is
seafoam everything outside of this door
what are you doing over there what are
you doing was that me i don't think that
was you
i just said there's no boxes over there
why would we not kill them
all right okay you guys came through i
was just getting in the plan of saying
let's foam up the entirety of this area
so nothing can get done but whatever no
they break them while i'm here i'm here
i'm sitting on the floor so that they
get stuck up with [ __ ]
so that they can't move
you had me to come
that was like one of the last things he
said shot
everybody in position
yeah
charge him up all right
three two one get him that's bad oh
you're the guy i'm backing up i'm
backing up i'm backing off i'm backing
off i'm running away i'm running away
yep yep i'm not coming back i'm not
coming back i've run away they're dead
they're dead they're dead they're all
right good all right i did it headshot
headshot
it's weird how when i quit hitting the
head the head quit blowing up
wow
not the pointy fingers wow
all right well okay that is a good point
the heads weren't blowing up so i like
that is a good point
that's a good point it's a good point
okay wait you can spear the tentacle guy
this time because clearly i [ __ ] it up
last time
[Music]
definitely there are more big guys in
here by the way you want to snipe them
or do our new tactic
uh
the news
tactic
and
wait how many are there wait there's
four here right here yeah let's get in
position on the one on the far left
and try and take him out and i can snipe
the three that will come from the right
side and the far one in the back if if
it goes wrong if you're flexing in you
know
no no i think it's far enough yes
uh oh i would like pattern but i think
if i do i'll lose [ __ ] these guys and
[ __ ] their moms who all right now i'm in
position all right
um uh
wait for them to come back first they're
glowing wait a second and if you park
them up if they
run right two one get them
it's not dead it's not dead
oh god one
it's almost like we're here we're good
they're done we're gonna go okay okay
he's good we're gonna work out we're
good
he's an ace
it's fine it's fine one shot three kills
two
six wait
wait how many seafoam grenades are there
i have one three ivan and there's one
back in the room we just came from oh
then i have one there are there are five
sea foam grenades there are five
tentacles
are you sticking yeah
can you see foam then with that yes all
of the tentacles
are important
well even if we get a couple of them
yeah even if we get it we can alert even
more yeah then we could kill them
as they're seafoamed
none could alert
and they can't trigger anything you guys
will kick my legs up and listen and let
me uh uh so hard to see i'm almost
positive
almost positive
from it's not going to reach but
remember if you charge you throw further
yeah hang on let me let me i'll i'm
going to try to find this one on the
right
if you miss do they trigger i don't
think so
no no
can't we just here we go let me try this
one
[Music]
it froze it's frozen it's frozen
okay i don't know how long that lasts
okay
repeat
okay so it's got to be quick we got to
like snap him and then someone's right
behind to hit him did did you not even
by the time you get there it's going to
unstick sean come with me
oh my god oh my god sorry i threw it i
spoke what the hell don't should i
should i oh yes go yes the tentacles are
gone it's too late it's too late to get
back out
already
okay wait they're all in the middle what
if we
yeah it's so that's all of them right
that's all of them yeah what if we skirt
around the edges actually we can do that
now yeah if all hell breaks loose run
back to that door and we're just gonna
have to alamo in that little room
yeah
oh right there okay
if you get behind this i think it won't
wrap around hit him
oh god oh god oh god there's another one
on the right yeah yeah we're good we're
good there's another locker over here
i'm going to keep i'm going to keep
pushing and sort of scouting
keep them paying for the love of god
mark yeah i beg you old medkit oh oh
right on me guys right around this
pillar
but get behind the pillar you're not
safe sean you're not safe just to our
left oh [ __ ]
behind this pillar next to me oh god
this reminds me of college wait are you
getting are we missing one on the ping
okay no we got the right there
if you get a back head shot on those
with a spear you you take it buddy
okay there's two by the door we need to
get through
okay i've got a seafoam
[Music]
around i've got a med pack and tool kit
over here in these lockers that i'm at
what is that it's glitching [ __ ]
you guys okay
oh we're good we're good we're good okay
i i don't think i was able to ping all
right can someone get to him
it didn't work
oh my god are you okay
we're fine we're just kind of pinned in
a corner right now okay oh he's he's
slurping again careful i think we need
to move in and try and take this close
one out guys
i think i think it's gonna have to be a
bold how did you know if that get him we
might have a better chance of
sandwiching in that room this long
hallway it's such a long time
one yeah
all right watch out there's uh i did not
get the ping i did not get the ping on
that one
we're good okay you can actually kind of
like just walk at them you don't need to
crawl yeah you can stand up and walk at
them that does not trigger them we don't
need to drop get them weighed
oh we tripped it we tripped
oh god
god dang it i got ammo pack who needs
ammo real quick
i think i think he said i'm okay oh why
didn't you kill it it didn't work
yeah look at this long approach i think
this is our best bet because we can see
him come from a really long way
can you ping mark can you hang in the
fog
hold on
pinging now oh my god what did i ping
then
[Music]
watch out you guys in front of my turtle
that's a turret
okay i'm trying to ping again we got
more there's more i got you
only got the one there might be more
coming
actually no that's it because there was
only one that tripped oh it wasn't all
five of them oh my god
the last one i think it was either me or
sean touched one
kill the other one his tentacle came out
and i actually killed the one that was
on me right as he started the tentacle
so i thought it was gonna be me but then
he just died we got tool refills here
like two of them okay health packs on
two people mark needs help if we have
any more health yeah uh let me give you
ammo bob would need more health after
that thank you well at least now we know
we can kill those guys a bit easier yeah
still stressful but yeah we we did it
well there was five of them i'm gonna
give you this anyway just to top you up
uh
speed dicey i got it oh it wasn't for
you it was a thing oh it's one of these
come here hey stand still hey this isn't
an alarm is it no no no okay all right
no it's just a weird scan for no reason
oh
i guess you have to clear the room to do
the scan is the thing i bet it was you
just avoid them
and you hit these when you can around
them yeah no i think killing them was
more fun than cool okay hopefully we get
another checkpoint
checkpoint checkpoint
yeah this looks like important
yeah what's on the other side because i
thought i heard a was that a checkpoint
nope that was a artifact
oh damn it oh that's darkness that's
fine hey look uh artifact it's fine you
need him
this room clear
yeah
oh there's something in the box hey
that's a thing we needed
i forgot that happened
i wish you could collect like a resource
while we were here like these obelisks
yeah that'd be cool or if there were
like artifacts but you had to like break
them out or something oh god oh that's a
lot mark can you possibly ping them you
got doable that's doable you got it
uh wow more came in
there's a lot that are not pinged yeah
yeah hold on hold on oh my god all right
okay hold on
oh hey look there they are that's a lot
it's turned into risk of rain
ow wow who the hell
everyone chasing you
chasing you there's like a whole [ __ ]
ton chasing they love me
oh
i'm down oh okay hold on oh god they
keep hammering me oh my god that is so
many over there oh
holy i was trying to conserve
auto time i'm playing baby oh god oh god
oh god i'm getting cornered thank you
no there's so many ways that's a bad
area oh god this is awful i shouldn't be
here bad everywhere bad everywhere this
is bad this is bad
oh god it's bad
oh i'm down don't die
just live i'm i'm running and jumping
i'm at all i'm slowed when they hit you
they slow you i think we all have to be
alive to get back
no way no way uh-uh no really
that would be down because we're all
dead
wait survive
i'm trying to get there's no way
they're literally everywhere oh no
should have put sentries down yeah
i had a century down it didn't help
oh
my god
all right speedrun
oh yeah at least we're getting good at
the game right guys oh hey yeah practice
practice practice oh good
[Laughter]
just watch you [ __ ] stumble past me
and then murder him
they call me the drunken stabber
i miss
hey good hit good work everybody
really
oh god oh it's about time to be in that
church
uh probably wade
no mine's up top
oh mine was up top if i remember
correctly you lie bob you [ __ ] looks
like it's time for knife uh hey mark you
might not well mark mark wait i did mark
don't
listen i see a green line again turret
mark i moved it because everyone was
complaining about it so i moved oh i got
him
all right i wish that was the thing here
doesn't sound as cool as saying knife
all right
wait
stop believing
three two one get
them what do you mean talented what do
you mean talented
did you say we were so talented
is that what you said
oh they're alerted holy geez this door
is foamed
[Music]
this is fine i'm fine they can't climb
loud okay good
first try oh hey guys
those sentries worked wonders oh
that sounds good it sounds good guys
sounds good it's going really well just
as good as ever you guys are pro the
spear bros
are spear pros maybe don't say it yet
[Music]
everybody ready yep anybody want the
peanut
oh we should get some bigger high grades
maybe here up here looks good yeah just
uh wait wait this way this way this way
this looks good here oh they're right
they're all over your weight
we don't overhang as well
oh god oh wait put your turret actually
put can you put your turn on this left
hallway
because they will funnel down this left
hallway very aggressively they're right
above us oh never mind that's terrifying
higher up
okay
got those
left hallway above the left hallway
right
now ow what the [ __ ] how is that hitting
there
okay we're good we're good
right above us
yeah we got nice coverage in the rocks
so we're okay
okay okay okay oh there you are coming
in above again coming in above again
okay they're so loud
all right we're we're actually good
we're good
there's one like yeah there's one screen
left let me ping anything
yeah they're more new wave coming in one
above there
can i get out from that rock you [ __ ]
oh it's they're being really cheeky
oh he's not hiding anymore
jeez
right in front of us
thank you okay we're good we're good let
me ping again and teleport
please
get a few more questions
[Music]
one percent health
oh
oh we got a checkpoint no i said no
checkpoint oh oh why why why no
why
not stop talking we got all the all the
tool packs all everything right
no there's med kit here there's a med
pack and a tool kit of tool pack with
lots of tool packs do you guys miss this
i don't think so do they restock no you
missed this this is the area i thought
you had checked yeah yeah i did but i
can't carry three packs well i didn't
remember you saying that work i just
heard that hey medpack i said two med
pictures
but it's okay you guys were busy i know
i'm going to give you a toolkit as well
speed dicey wait isn't that better on
you guys we're full man yeah we're all
up man we are not utilizing our sentries
properly hey my sentry killed several
well we just refilled them too yeah no i
just used wait just use like two fills
on me and to fill on himself i'm sorry i
keep criticizing it i don't need to i
know that it's you that are i'll i'll
knife
this door
okay well i could open that after you
gotta be clean
we have to go to the red door now yeah
the funky door
i didn't like that door right can we not
do that we got here one dude in the
shadows off to the left one dude left
okay maybe not no try
we should unlock it right now yeah
there's there's nothing near us so you
can probably do it do it oh yeah there's
definitely maybe probably there's one
yep let them sleep yeah we they're
sporadic in this room we've been through
here before
nice nice spear
thank you
oh look at those beers and knives
working together
they're in prime knife territory right
now oh oh god
i get this guy you sprint at the second
one okay you got it
i'll get him sprinting
get him oh so oh there's another one in
the darkness here
get him get him oh he's knifing him oh
well i lost 17 health that's okay i've
got an explosion more more more
there was one up top i was trying to
sneak up to is you all [ __ ] up
we're good we're good okay okay
okay guys
and there's a tool refill pack oh wait i
can carry this
i i can carry something too we find
right
this is the steep home grenade
seafoam grenade you say good idea
uh
oh you're right we're good i guess
um looks like these three yes and then
one off to the right on that ramp
i'm gonna go for the beauty oh you're
gonna go for the back one i see
oh yeah
all right i'm ramping i'm going
oh my god
it's a checkpoint oh i'm gonna comb
oh
no
sean we just need you yep
i'm just near all five of these dudes
it's fine oh is there more dudes i
forgot
we could go help
now
all right hey guys
follow me
oh
[Music]
my god is there anything behind this
door before it opens itself
no this is the big middle part what is
this door lacroix
what craw why do you say that whoa
yeah lacroix that's it
it's weird how there's a checkpoint
there's nothing left to fight
for medpack
oh no for us but oh no
you're probably right look
look down there there's a bunch of
there's a there's some orange things
down there can we get down there is
there stairs in here yeah i'm all the
way down here i think these guys are
growing weed down here
oh
this is this is where they get there
good that's illegal in this whole
dimension oh i also have a security
protocol and nearby terminal to operate
this door okay
sure sure
oh no i want to open the box i used the
ammo pack the second time
maybe don't equip the ammo pack there's
two more ammo packs in this one that's a
lot of ammo packs that is concerning
yeah i have a four use tool refill oh my
god there's a four use and a three use
med pack in the same box yeah that's not
a good sign
i think this is gonna go really badly
wait what are we looking for i found a
terminal oh stuff oh hey that's the
thing we need because you gotta do the
uh reset security protocol
oh okay well i'll wait yeah maybe until
we're all grouped up somewhere yeah
should we be down here then uh that's
you know what that's an interesting
question
they probably come from everywhere and
drop down so it's like
can we go anywhere that funnels them i
think it's just from everywhere i think
we should hide in a stairwell all
together yeah i'm just gonna well you
got a checkpoint let's just see what
happens yeah let's just see what happens
i guess true yeah just i'll stay up here
so i can i don't know look at everything
all right
i should reset security protocol hang on
a second oh boy all right well what's
gonna think about
my security bob you want me to blow your
mind right now
what's that
hit tab when you're typing
oh
hang on wait how far how far does that
go oh it does the whole thing
and i typed the r and it typed the whole
thing
[Laughter]
yeah i wish i hadn't told you because i
i like seeing you floundered
oh they're coming now
oh [ __ ] it's the fire [ __ ] oh god
sure fine my bad's grumping i'm coming
my bad how was the view up there was it
good
awesome
[Music]
yeah i don't like that very much at all
well it's okay we didn't waste much time
we're probably fine we're behind
and let me ping let me ping it
you guys have turned sound
no
one went down right now
and security scanning it's only at 10
oh no it's at 12. guys there wait
oh my god
almost just
it's going to go all the way up top
isn't it
yep you're right oh my god why am i in
here can we grab our sentiment yeah
yeah you probably should
i am losing all of my health i i we
can't shoot if you go into knife
there's one inside of one of you
i'm grabbing my turret oh my god
not being arrogant shut up yeah they're
already coming down
this
[Music]
okay i'm gonna put a mine down behind us
ahead of us as well we're wrapping into
the same area here
good night
good night oh my god that's a lot of
them
ah come here you [ __ ]
god damn it
place you [ __ ] god damn we up thank you
okay the first part this one is if one
goes down we can't do it
hey guys we're like a third of the way
[Music]
it doesn't get harder as it goes
let's see i'm pinging again we got
another group coming down
that's a pink i popped the big heart do
you want to shoot them before they run
from behind wait circle circle
us
sorry i'll get out of the way
no no you don't
ow
okay i'll watch out i'm gonna run for my
turn again
yeah yeah i'm gonna get my turret
halfway no enemies in range
oh here they come
they're coming out of that door the top
door they're only coming out of the top
door
we should push it okay turn something
down
in the circle circle yeah okay so if we
have to do this over we'll uh gunk it up
and put our turrets up there
get out of here we're leaving a turret
behind us
oh
hey circle's moving fast now
oh [ __ ]
i'm officially out there got gun ammo
i'm gonna turn again
oh god sorry i didn't wow
it's okay
you guys are covering yeah yeah yeah
covering me yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah covered
just discovered
all right good cover okay i have a mine
as well i didn't know where to put it
well i think they're just coming out
this literally this door we're going
through i think that's where they're
coming through
yeah so with two turrets oh yeah
yeah but no but you can see from the
ground and then turn it up
and i'm also going to put a trip mine
right here do we want one like aimed
across the middle to try and get flyers
or that's probably not worth it we only
showed up at the start and then we're
gone we want to thin the door out yeah
that's ideal i'm just gonna have my name
right down the middle of the door yeah
actually that's a good idea i think i
might as well just do this you're gonna
keep pouring out regardless so um are we
gonna gunk this up a little bit uh yeah
before we start we should see foam this
but
um don't know
it degrades over time so not until we're
ready to go i think it lasts five
minutes is what i remember looking at
okay well it's gonna take us a solid
five minutes to get all the loot again
yeah i say we send sean up with a full
tool kit and he just like blows the
entire odd gonna blow their mind all
right i'm as topped off as i
gonna get is there any heels around i'm
only at 72. there should have been at
least like one more up there someone got
more heels or something i was only at 60
to start last time and everyone said we
were out so i don't know okay i think
sean healed me up 472 is high enough
which door is it it's like when we came
in
where the turrets are
oh yeah
you gotta block them here and then you
gotta come around here and then we're
gonna flank them around this side and
we're gonna dig a hole through the wall
here and bam
the real problem area is like
here
here they're gonna come that way yeah
you're right yeah
like that they're gonna be coming in all
over those flanks yeah now the turrets
are great because they're right about
here right and right about here and this
is their arc
yeah so well and minus mine is over here
right so it's kind of yeah yeah it's got
in between what you're talking about
yeah we're trying to funnel them into
something that's really containable area
they're coming through here we're here
and we want to funnel them down into a
smaller try to figure out what genitals
you're drawing by just the sound
i think mark is drawing a human heart
oh the greatest genital of them all
the
love muscle
[Music]
that's what i call my penis are we
spiced up yeah i'm here let's go using
my newly acquired hacker skills
that mark taught you and here we go oh
it moves all right let me start let me
actually ping quicker
here they go
do you think they're all dying up there
i hear pain oh god you're going this way
i'm here enough pain but i hear
something uh-huh
oh that sounds so good
i like that they're gonna run out of
ammo so fast no they're bursts
as long as we can get to like 30 percent
first we're fine yeah well so far
already this is better
yeah we haven't seen the flyers yet
i think the flyers didn't make it out
like i know
i know security systems need to be
convoluted to uh i said mark sorry sorry
i want the other one here
whoever designed this like
yeah
[ __ ] you just like i have the best idea
for protocols
to be fair there's something there's
some coming i didn't tag them already
no it's a cool game mechanic just if
this was my if this was a security
system at a real job
people would be like god [ __ ] hate
okay they are slowly making their way to
us i don't know why so slow slowly and
not sure there might be a little goopy
or something okay here comes one here
comes one
i hear him
there's another
oh here come here
stay in the zone stay in the zone
[Music]
yeah zone is more important
oh
what hit him
oh
ah ah in my soul
candice
all right keep going keep going
boys [ __ ] them up yeah let me ping again
that's what we're looking at
nice okay anything in front of us uh
ones
where are you what the hell right there
whoa they're jumping all over the place
on my screen
i lost the zone my bad oh inside the
zone there's one inside the zone
we are in the zone
i think we're meaning different things i
don't know if we're communicating
correctly
what a good team leader he is oh come on
no hey guys listen
autos are good
can you die you got a lot lot coming in
there they are oh boy
okay reloading i'm gonna reclaim the
high ground
keep going keep going okay we're clear
for now out of the unmarked oh it's
going this way oh it's three quarters
oh it's good that's good
turrets are still firing that's awesome
that's awesome we love that oh this way
that's cool i love that for us i love
that for us we're in the zone we're in
the zone
and hear you zoning right now
zoning like a bonus oh down below oh
right there
there's this thing going
it's wrapping around to the left i think
getting the circle it's wrapping around
and then it's going to go over to the
left mark it's really dark i've been
chain pinging
okay
it's gonna go up these stairs oh yeah
eighty-eight percent big group
big group big group big group coming oh
this way got them
yeah
they're this is where the groups come
from
oh
buddy
i'm falling back i'm giving space right
now to clear this a little bit
okay clearly right behind you guys that
won't die all right there we go one
above us
i'm out of a main weapon i don't have
ammo i have ammo i have ammo ignore me
i'm an idiot
okay just stay in circle
whoa hey hello oh did not ping those
okay watch out big group coming in
oh [ __ ] oh yeah group with the big with
the big
i will try and snipe the big when it
comes into the
area
it's a big shooter
okay i just need to got it got it
okay okay get this guy in the air
there's a flyer okay okay
okay 96 97 78 this is the end
once this is over we win yes
[Music]
at a time in the thing all right uh
locate we're at two out of three data
cubes and we're done with the security
but what does that mean for us just
finish these guys
i'm out of ammo i need to ammo pack
myself real quick
okay we
are clear that one's not dead on the
ground there
good job
that one's not that either
okay
i'm all good
through a lot of ammunition
that's what it's there for good thing we
probably don't have another uh
portal zone well this isn't a security
one so no i don't even know who to give
i have two ammo uses who even needs it i
have zero shotgun on 26 pistol why are
you getting on the circle in the circle
because i'm waiting for him to amble you
in case okay okay that turret strat
worked really nicely there was a lot
left there for a long time yeah
good gooping sean
[Laughter]
oh get sticky [ __ ] so many
[Music]
lady we're trying to talk here
i know
i don't wanna your
uh just one box in here by the looks of
it uh data cube we're going to teleport
if i pick this up okay okey dokey oh god
well i feel ready maybe we should make
sure we get the tool record for yourself
another room let me
let's look at the console to see if
there were any packs that we missed
the only two resources left on the map
is an ammo pack and a tool refill those
both be very handy for this next spot
let me just query them real quick see
where they are they might be right
[ __ ] might be these ones uh 143
that's way way in the back ammo packing
143 tool refill 900s and 145 they're in
rooms 143 and 144 the tool refill only
has 20 capacity the weapon has two
charges 143 is way back it's way back
and one over here
okay
if there's any flyers left anyway yeah
maybe this last teleport is easy
maybe it teleports us into a bath
teleport to freedom and we're finally
released from this hell c1 seems like
the last level
after what they just threw at us they
would give us more stuff if there was
more fighting yeah
i don't think they should or they're bad
developers yeah that's what i'm thinking
but the facts are right i'm glad you
said it all right let's get it oh yeah
pick it up pick it up all right
all right everything hopefully it
doesn't it
oh what the hey
what is this then oh god where is this
oklahoma oh what is this
oh we need to find a shelter we need to
find a shelter you got any skins
what do you mean big creature where whoa
you didn't hear that no
yes yeah he wasn't here though i didn't
think that was a creature you know i
didn't think it was
i thought it was way in the distance
doing weight stuff
oh are we done are we done
are we done
oh my god is this the extraction point i
see it beyond
i think we're done i see it as well oh
my gosh see through the window no shot
dude oh hedgehog no shot bro
do you guys hear that yeah it sounds
like a liquid monster that we can easily
kill
yes
guys i don't hear him
oh it's coming what
it's gone
i'm coming
take seven attempts to finish that easy
level
oh only two hours and 20 minutes boys
wow
oh my god
oh my god what is this what is a c
symbol c for cool
see your mama later tonight oh
all right guys
who's up for another
[Music]